this is crazy I can't believe you're
really doing this I know it's definitely
real when you start putting it in the
suitcases I'm excited for you I'm
excited I'm nervous for you
it's hard being together you know first
couple years are great and then reality
sets in and you have to work through all
that stuff that's true
last year May Lisa had an opportunity to
come for six months on her tourist visa
and the plan was to take that
opportunity to buy a ring propose get
engaged finally and then a month you
know before she came I cheated on her I
think yeah every couple has their
struggles but I think the struggles that
we were having or maybe more directly
attributed some things that I personally
needed to work on everybody always has
things to work on yeah but not everybody
cheats when she came to visit me Lisa
had her suspicions she had discovered by
my social media if something was up so
that's what prompted her to kind of you
know start digging and she eventually
confronted me about it after that we
started arguing all the time you think
she'll ever really be able to put it
behind her though
[Music]